the key to winning this tournament is to
connect oh it's it's back okay
ah join okay we're back
only burned hey i won the game
i've i won my first game with lost a
second
who that i play
why is it all the players disappeared
oh no 18
755 players
i'm in 1222
berserking my first
game ah okay let's play this
opponent wasn't pre-moving
wait i deserve i thought like berserk
did it not work
i swear i hit the berserk button
also quack quack
the tournament is the biggest only chess
ever
yeah we're breaking it
um
happy 10 months eric thanks for all the
content maybe it just lagged there
thank you son of a shepherd
i want to play a6
someone already has 20 points
hey eric sub anniversary i'll be waiting
for g5 moves
i just blundered
hey eric good luck thank you thank you
have to be really careful here let's
play keaney chates
idea that so if i get forked
never mind
i'm being really reckless
um
[Music]
play this move
i have this idea which i'm going for
i'm just trying to win quickly i'm not
even threatening oh now i'm turning this
the queen was on c2 could have defended
let's go
i want a game hey
this person wins one bitcoin
tcon09
that's insane time to win
i'm photographing this for proof
and this person must be so happy right
now
okay they're probably making another
link for the tournament
where did i finish
i didn't even finish in the roster of
players
can i search for my name
oh i finished in 12 38
with two points
that's unfortunate
oh leech has tweeting new link
okay no one retweeted it it has to be
secret
we can't advertise it so
uh
so fewer players will join
ah twitter is broken
yeah this is probably the most chaotic
experience of my life
where'd i go again hey it's reenigma
even rey enigma's playing
that's so funny
i wonder if karpov is playing
so they recreated the link
and already there's almost 10 000
players joined
okay nine
eight
seven
six
five
four
three we might have issues but we'll see
good luck to everyone zero
wait for it wait for it 169. oh i'm
playing sophia
that's berserk
stop for gamba time
no staffing out of time
italian time
i'll bring the queen to e6
uh that's
difficult berserking
cloud95
oh no
i can't ah that doesn't quite work
let's try taking and taking
yeah this doesn't quite work
i resign okay
um the hope is i i play a weaker player
i can berserk and hopefully win quicker
ah i'm playing as an i am
[Music]
okay berserk's back at least we have a
bullet game
okay london opening time
i already like the position
the typical idea is kh1g4
a lot of pressure on black
on some meat okay let's go no time to
waste
okay let's berk again
play e4 this time
grand prix attack time
check is okay
not kind of risky opening but it's
interesting
unite g3 knight h5 or knight f5
i'll play this
i'm targeting this pawn
trying to take
man there's no
standings each has probably sacrificed
the standings to save some bandwidth
so i don't know oh i'm top 100 though
let's go
okay targeting the pawn now
queen finds a happy place 93 i sack
want to go after c5
jack
okay centralize the queen
fighting rook f7
as
close
good luck eric
thanks
it still takes a lot of work here
i think this is okay
this is not okay
good luck in the tournament
no i'm losing this
maybe black doesn't know
please tell me please please
appointment has trouble here
no
i almost almost survived that was a long
game too
i tried
i got berserk every game i think is a
strategy
south africa wolf
play b5
yeah this is
looking solid actually
tricky tricky
good move play off six and take
each no let's play knight d7
f5 hitting the pawn
okay maybe winning back some material
but maybe not because my rook's hanging
takes takes i think this is okay
actually
so bishop a three in the end and bishop
b2
and preventing rook d7
tickle the rook
okay trying to advance
there we go okay this is pretty
straightforward wind now
okay
zamax in first
okay the goal is to go for the
immediate media kingside attack
so rook g1 and g4
h3
g4
uh that's a good move
you'd have to be a bit more patient here
okay invade c6 yeah it's a bit more
positional
[Music]
but still pretty happy
queen is almost trapped
probably shouldn't have traded queens
okay pretty simple win now
okay not wasting time
321 stafford gambit time
no
i blundered a bishop
ah that was such a bad bishop to blender
to
try and fight back though
[Music]
no trades
i want to bring my knight to e6
okay let's try this trade bishops
i blundered a rook
opponent doesn't take it
die blunder the queen
i'm still surviving
a opponent plunders back okay
sometimes you have to give to receive
okay let's feast on some pawns
i'm kind of smelling it
i'm really smelling it
i was really smelling it there
let's go
okay
oh stalemate
let's go
okay i'm i'm happy for the the
tournament now
oh 132 let's go is that a new peak heart
rate
it might be
oh i feel so accomplished
okay e4 is a alpha zero idea
bishop d2 queen b4 is the only move here
and what's the line like knight d4
let me trade
actually bishop d3 i think
some alpha zero stockfish game
okay really trying to play like alpha
zero here
i really want to tin let's play this
move first
it's a fun looking position
i think this is okay if takes queen f6
bishop f8 i take now you're just having
an h6 in the end
okay that's a free thing
oh
[Music]
that's still not over
let's take for fun
i'm down
a lot of stuff
but i have ompassant
i have a lot of time too
threatening me i allow the queen trade
um
not mating
because i'm not mating
what is this material imbalance
no
let's go okay
oh what a dirty game ahaha
uh let's berserk again
319
four nights opening
assume this is some sort of opening prep
theory type thing
don't mind the queen trade
and bishop b5 could be annoying
[Music]
i might be losing a pawn unfortunately
it's not the end of the world
more concerned about bishop f6 there
um
this funny move
we're just trading stuff both queens are
hanging
let's play rook a8 or b8
bishop d5
and checkmate
let's go
i'm playing a game what no i'm not
okay top 200 let's go
i'm on some sort of streak
yeah locks played this well already
it's still interesting though
i just have to keep playing aggressively
uh does this really work
it takes
oh it seems like there should be
something but maybe there's not
play this move
it was crazy
oh no my queen please take it please
please
i resigned
i was rough
i had to go for the last trick though
okay stafford gambit time
so knight c3 i've had knight g4
here i'll just try and play as
aggressively as possible
got my queen out
be careful of like getting my queen
trapped though if i moved here there's a
queen trap
yeah this is already not looking good
okay now i'm just worse
i'm down the pawn bad structure
we traded queens
but i'll try and fight
the good thing about being down the pawn
is i have an open g file
wait current donation is 150
150 bpm
[Music]
okay
i have to do some jumping jacks at some
point
oh no i'm losing a bishop
uh
maybe this move
not looking so great though
interesting
if anything i'll win this game on time
[Music]
hopefully
good move oh i have this move let's go
okay
bishop is saved so there's a pin
f5
can still go for the
eventual king side attack
i sack
attack
maybe i'm meeting
am i
it's really close to mates
oh turning made in one
okay let's go
i'm playing a gm
[Music]
and gm's mop is working back
berserking is really risky here
thanks for subbing eric pal
appreciate it
bishop takes out almost winning
am i winning here
how does black defend
uh check check let's play this
first we need bishop g6
let's take that
it's looking good
it's a good move let's play this
it takes i have this move
while
this move
this looks really good
where's my wind
are you even threading anything
what's the game
no my queen
oh i'm so tilted
ah
[Music]
oh i was so close to meeting there
that's so sad
okay at least i'm top 500 still
it's gonna be really hard to win a
bitcoin or even play magnus or hikaru
and play one of these
good luck eric
thanks i'm gonna need more of it
okay
so i have a night
i think i'm winning already so this i
take
and take the queen uh even better is
this move
i'm just winning a queen flat out
let's go 12 move stafford win
with berserking
playing ponky i should not beserk this
game
so i have the full two minutes i think
this might be my first game not
berserking
whenever they play b6 h4 is called for
queen f3
unleashing some komski style opening
prep
and threatening this and this and this
merry christmas oh king hey they take
yeah there's multiple tactical threats
here
thank you troy maples
so top 300
it's nice having the pawn here because
normally there'd be knight h5 but
the rook now covers h5
it's really hard to defend king h7 i
have this move
also g6 is prevented
okay i'll take there
now the light squares are weak
black doesn't have a light squared
bishop uh might as well take and castle
[Music]
someday queen here
i really want to play knight g5 but
let's play this first slow and steady
but not too slow
threatening made in one
again threading made in one
where's my mate
not seeing it
i guess i can take this
knight g6 it's winning
this was a really nice game really nice
feel good london game
got the opening crap got a nice attack
let's
go okay
highest rated win so far
now berserk again
london time this time from the block
side
okay we're playing into like a very
comfortable line for black this is a
major idea
and now i can't really def oh i can
defend but now i'm attacking two pawns
actually miss knight g6
preventing the knight from
coming in
maybe some idea to maneuver
into b3
defending d5
this is slightly annoying
rookie six
hi eric hope you're doing well i am
hi to 18 emilio
i feel pretty good so far
want to play this next and
neutralize the pressure
go eric
thank you winter mule
oh
oh okay i can take this and i have two
knights for a rook
king of threes coming
now i'm threatening a fork
oh it's not easy to win this actually
white might be in zugzwang here like the
king has to move somewhere awkward
i'm gonna prepare f5
that didn't really help
check oh this is frustrating
let's go
let's go i won i won let's go nights are
so tricky
okay what a dirty flag
kept surviving and kept holding onto the
pawn
double wizard game
rate 132
trying to be charitable with my heart
rate
okay it's almost mate
cutting this
okay i don't care about my bishop
so if takes i take
now let's double check
what is this position
between c3 aligning defending
um
might as well take
oh funny line rick takes c6
uh am i winning this
c4
deflection pong
i'm deflecting one of these things away
from defending e8s that's so funny
let's go what a game
that was a funny game
okay trying to
get into top 100
i'm playing a bit strangely here
some a regular reminder that in canadian
french all personally really means by
the way ah thanks for the reminder
appreciate it
f5
rav4
almost trapping the queen but not quite
queen e3 is now a threat
so this knight is uh needs a babysitter
um
they're hoping for rook ae1
that's a good move
knight g6 is nice though because
what to do with the rook
finding this now
okay
to use the files up the exchange
we have four
a lot of pressure
a ton of pressure here on whites
but not so much time for me
c5 and bishop a4
it's almost trapped
16 seconds
it's winning
[Music]
safe remove
very very tricky if i took the queen
there's mate
opponent probably said oh no my queen
okay let's go that's a nice game nice
blizzard quinn
opponent didn't berserk back 70th place
playing asapanko
well i photographed a world cup
took some funny photos of him
trying to play solidly
ah that's not a solid move
take this takes takes
this is okay
now he's playing grand mastery
positional chess
we're going to get a really close
position
and it's going to turn into a flag fest
play f4 here
oh that was probably a really bad
decision
i feel cramped
for the rook on c2
he's squeezing me
this move
some still matrix
i have to go for the ultimate stalemate
check
go i got checkmated
i thought it was being solid then he
squeezed me
and he didn't fall for any tricks
okay
500.
had this opening earlier
playing super aggressively here
opponent could have won the d4 pawn
instead gifting me a pawn
queen belongs on d3
as free pawn again
g4 may be coming
up a lot of pawns
i can still castly or castle legally
both ways
another v-pawn
never too late to castle
[Music]
another free pawn
opponent was very generous that game
i was being showered in free pawns
opponents not berserking opponents
higher rated than me by over 100 points
staff are gather time
opponent too afraid
it's a nice looking position but
time-wise it's going to be tough
i take this i can take that
tactics tactics
i want to do things along this diagonal
i could have taken that
okay still threatening this there's a
pin here
maybe threatening this now
[Music]
the queen is attacked
oh i'm threading a queen sack for mate
let's go
what a nice game
[Music]
berserk win against a stronger higher
rated player
okay
let's play one of these
what is this
some weird gambit type thing
i have to be really careful here
i feel like i'm walking into opening
prep
maybe not
bishop b4 um
it's still okay maybe
maybe not
but maybe
whoa
[Music]
whoa
i should be really careful
it might already be too late
oh no my queen and king
hey i'm playing with good friend of mine
i don't know if i should be working or
not okay i'll be zerk ray robson
we playing tennis sometimes
uh he knows this opening too
wait does he
no he doesn't
this is not a good line for black
can't complain too much with the opening
uh-oh
did i go wrong
i may have gone wrong
still playable though maybe
i want to take this pawn
and push my a pawn
oh e7 was hanging
i don't want to trade queens
what is this position
i'm so confused right now
i don't know what to do
oh no
well i'm up a queen temporarily but no
longer now i'm down two rooks
no
ah
he check it he checked me at me before i
could resign
okay playing lord mustard
walrus
we have a reverse two knights attack
love to greet gift
i'm offering f7
i'll play this move first
it's kind of interesting actually
deja vu anyone
deja vu hey it's love hey chess
didn't love his chest sub like the other
day
he's running bishop h3 now
whoa
[Music]
knight c3 i kind of want to play
82nd place it's not too bad
if rook c1 ever i play knight e2
okay here's a free bishop
okay when the apon
oops
this is still pretty good
[Music]
i don't care about my knights at this
point
bone's trying to flag me
okay
okay
108
playing uh ts oh i'm playing my uh
my long forgotten father
[Music]
hikaru that's my goal this stream right
this would be takara
uh
kind of nervous now
yeah we've played this line before
good luck
thank you
he's in first place he's in first place
i'm just trying to break the top hundred
oh my bishop
i got nervous i had a good position too
h g3
oh no
stop hurting me
wait did i trick him i think i tricked
him am i winning
he has no moves
how am i winning this
this is
wait let's be careful
chuck
let's go
oh i feel so powerful
let's go goal accomplished
i don't know how i won that
i was getting smashed
oh
i'm sorry hikaru
oh kind of shaky
hey 166.
again the top heart rates there will be
a charitable donation
let's go
let's go
so i can say i have a
a plus score against a car on each house
he should have won that though
somehow got like you're really really
lucky but i'll take it
okay not because working
thank you everyone
for your kind support
was this game
i forgot i'm in the midst of playing a
game
still remembering the previous game
i need some b5 idea
b5 work if i might work
bishop b3 expected
okay
that's a good move
uh let's play this move thank you
malcolm
okay so i win this pawn losing maybe
this pawn kakaroo bits
yeah
boom chaka rakanaka
play this move
i feel
[Music]
she feel pretty good
[Music]
overall
this position is a it's about to get not
so good
uh-oh
okay
i have the bishop hair
the problem is white also has a bishop
hair
uh opponent wants to hurt me
okay rookie seven
so the plan is to push pawns eventually
can i swindle my way in another game
maybe this move
check
no king d2
[Music]
action d1
let's try this first because rook g2
will come
eventually looks kind of passive
ah this isn't working
[Music]
okay i'll go for h4
i think's banana
in it to win it let's go in it to win it
61st place
i'm just kind of struggling in this
position
[Music]
whoa
oh no my queen and my king ah not again
okay
hey karo is leading though wow
i'm the first person to beat hikaru this
tournament
wow
166. carlson in fifth place
wait i'm playing a game
no i'm not
so the next goal is to be carlson
wait did he call him
he's actually insane this tournament and
you still won yeah
my car was in the lead by far
leech ass down again
did beating akaro break leech us
oh no
oh we beserked each other okay
yeah i was so
far in the zone that i don't
fully recall i'll have to rewatch what
happened here it is
i was so lucky i don't know how
that happened
i made five blenders this game but
hikaru made seven blunders
average sent upon lost 100
so what was the turning point
so i was just losing losing losing and
queen takes g3 and all of a sudden rook
f1
man and the knight was out of play
tournaments on pause
oh hikaru wasn't losing here but then
after
this oh king h8 was a blunder
i allowed queen f3 check
yeah king h6 man
oh
heart rate went to 165 against ikaru
i wonder what it would go to if i played
magnus
wait i missed maiden one against takaru
no
unless it's a troll
wait
yeah i had maiden one
it's okay
i won the more stylish way yo queen
yeah more like oh no hikaru's queen
i missed queen c8 i took some time here
too right took two seconds
ah i missed made in one
oh no lee chess is launching an
anti-cheat investigation on me
yeah this game was very suspicious
but the graph resembles a smiley face
oh i need to update the stream title
oh leech has tweeted
i don't want to write easyclap
i want to come across as
uh
[Music]
as someone who says easyclap
what do i tweet i'm having writer's
block
or tweeter's block
you're next and then tag magnus carlsen
just resign kappa
but winky face
winky face right
winky face makes it a bit lighter right
where's my winky face
where's the winky face there it is
or sunglasses
no winky face that's too too much
okay